基本的に私の最初の学期に
電話が
かかってきたので、学校を辞めたり休学したりする必要はありませんでした。
発送されたユニットはイラクに行き
、処理時間の終わりからそこに
いました。
私たちが戻ってきたときまでのすべての管理手順を経て、それは約1
年でした。
ええと、みんなここでドーガンになり
ました
。 基本的に無期限に一緒に仕事をする予定なので、君たちが彼をもう少しよく知ることができる
ように、私が本質的に彼にインタビューしているビデオな
ので、君たち
はその人を知ることに興味があるだろうと思っ
た
私はなぜ
彼らを過去の職業の観点から彼らの歴史を採用したの
か
、彼らが日本にどれくらい住んでいるのかなど、最初
にあなたが何歳
ですか、何歳ですか？ ええと
、40代後半、それは私たちがやるのは公平だと思い
ます 40代後半
になると、誰かを雇おうとしたときに頭に浮かんだことの1つは、
本当に有能
で熟練した
人が欲しかった
ことでした。
アジア太平洋大学
で作りましょう。その学校で知っていたすべての人のことを考えます
。jp
は、あなたが知っている人を雇うという点で、私が探していたものと一致する最高のスキルセットを持っていました。
その
スキルは彼の年齢で設定されました私は私が自分自身に思った
過去の会話を言うだろうと私は知らないことがたくさんあり
ましたああこれは私が持ってい
ないもののような知恵のようなものです
それは私も自分のビジネスに
取り入れたいと思っていた
ものです。あなたは毎日の生活を知っているだけです。あなたから学ぶことは
日本の父親でもあります。
たとえば、
あなたについて知っていることはたくさんあります。
ロカを通過する教育 l学校のシステムは
、
jpと一緒に仕事をすることで大きな恩恵を受けること
ができます。基本的に、毎日会うことはありませんが、
頻繁に会うことになります。
あなたの
基本的な年齢の私は人々が
おそらくそう疑問に思う
だろ
うと思いました
その数分
後、高校を卒業するまで上がることができます。
先に進んでください。私は元々、ロサンゼルスから
1時間ほど離れた南カリフォルニア
出身で、北に生まれ育ち
ました。
ネイティブのカリフォルニア人は
小学校に通いました。
小学校中学と
高校まですべて
同じ都市にあります私は実際に
は南カリフォルニアのベンチュラからですええ
あなたは若い頃に日本に興味がありましたか？
帽子は後で来たので
、1990年に高校を卒業しまし
た。おそらく中学校だった
と思います。大丈夫だと思います。
中学校のように
覚えています。中学校だったと思います。
あなたはおそらく
それが全体のモスフェットであったことをあなたが知っていることを知らないでしょ
うええとあなた
はアニメファンダムの中でマクロスええと一種のやり直し大丈夫ええ
と知っています
基本的なケーブルテレビを知っていたら
、それは私が早くから日本に行かなければならなかった唯一の露出でした。つまり
、図書館の教科書や本を知っている以外は知っているということ
です。
当時、アニメのよう
に主流にさえ近づいてい
なかったので、まったく
違う日と年齢
でした。なぜなら、私の世代の多くの人々が、
いわばアニメのようなものを通して、私のようなウィーブーになったからです。
アニメと武道の組み合わせのようなものです
が、それは正しい言葉ではなく、まったく無関係だった
と思いますが、あなたの世代には存在しませんでした。
ええと、ロボテック以外の最初のものだと思います。
私が本当に覚えている最初の
アニメええと、私は
ロールプレイングゲームのコンベンションに行きました。これ
はロサンゼルスやサンディエゴのようにダウンしていたでしょう。
今日のコンベンションのように
、
さまざまなショップがテーブルを設置しているベンダールームが
あります。 テーブルが少し戻ってきたので、
少し覗いてみたようです。
テーブルが
あったので、コンベンション
では今日のよう
に、ベンダールームがあり、ベンダールームにはベンダールームがあり
ました。 人々は物を売る漫画店の才能を
売っています
そして私は日本のアニメを演奏している1つのテーブルにああ小さなテレビがあったことを覚えています
そしてそれは
私が本当にそれを見たのは初めてでしたそして私
はtの品質を見たことを覚えています 彼のアニメーション
とあなたはそれがちょうど私に
印象を残したことを知っていましたあなたはそれが私に印象を残したことを知っていました
初版のように
昔のダンジョンズダンジョンズアンドドラゴンズのように
私がプレイしたオリジナルのumマーベルスーパーヒーロー
は当時ロールプレイングゲームを持って
いました
ええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ Robotechから10代の
ミュータント忍者タートル
、そして同じすごいロールプレイングシステム内のすべての異なるジャンルのすべての異なるタイプ
とええと、最後のええとええと
、ええと、ええと、ええと、ええと、ええと、ええと、ええと、ええと、ええと、ええと、ええと、ええと、ええと、ええと、ええと、ええと、ええと、ええと
、友達と一緒にかなり 人々が尋ねる
次の質問は興味深い
です私は6歳なのであなたはどれくらい背が高いですか私は
ここでステージに立つには
高すぎます日本に住むには高すぎますええええと
100そして私は私の足で立っています
広がる約広がる 少しだ
から私は実際
にフレーム内にいることができますええと190394
センチメートル
はフィートで
ええと6、4、6、4は少しええ、私は
すでに
日本のようにドアの
ようなもので少し問題を抱えています
伝統的な家で
、あなたにとってどんな感じか想像さえできませんが、
長い話をすると、私たちは両方とも日本で椎間板ヘルニアを持っていた
ので、
私が行ったすべてのものの料理をするために背を向けました
シンクがとても低いので、実際には同じことをしまし
た。ディスク
をつかみに行きました。
向きを変えてグラスをつかみに行きました。背中が出
て、床に倒れました。
ええ、私のものはそれほど突然ではありませんでした。
私のはもっと似ていて
、
私はそうだったそうそうそうそうそうええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ
日本で背が高いことに対処するはい、
あなたが日本に着いた方法を学び始めましょう。
高校を卒業してから
日本に着くまでの時間はもう少し長いです。それはあなた
にとって興味深い話だと知っている
からです。
それは従来のジェット
プログラムとは
異なります。 これは誰にとっても標準的な
話です。高校を卒業して
から大学に行き、大学を卒業すると
ジェットプログラムの仕事をします。私
は高校を卒業
しました。コミュニティカレッジを少し試してみました。
私は
実際に大学に直接進学するための学年や経済的手段を持っていません
でしたが、私はさまざまな個人的な
理由で
コミュニティカレッジが私にはなかったので
、約1年後に中退し
て小売業で働きました
しばらくの間、それらのいくつかを持っていて
、それから私は軍の予備のリクルーターと話をすることになり
まし
た、
そして私はちょうど私が
彼が私の質問に答えたと答えた質問をしました
あなたは高圧販売か何かを知っています
ええと私は予備軍に参加する
ことになりました私は私の人生で何もしていなかったことを意味します私は
どこにも行きませんでした
そして私は興味があったので私は予備軍に参加しました
軍隊全体の一部として大丈夫ですので、米軍の
中には、
それを単純に保つことを知っていることがあります
予備軍があり、国家警備隊が
あります予備軍は
連邦のパートタイマー
であり、必要なときに軍隊を埋め戻すことができます
警備員は
ほとんど同じですが、
国家警備隊
と私はこれを単純に保とうとしています
ええ、国家警備隊は
州に属し
ているので、
災害が発生し
たときに国家警備隊が呼び出されることがよくあります
それらは州の資産
であり、法執行機関としても使用できるため、
これは些細なことですが、
そういうわけで、それらはすべて頻繁
に呼び出されるので、次のようなときに呼び出されるのです。
あなたは暴動や平和維持などを知っています
が
、予備役は、予備
役のメンバーとして
月に1週間、その後2、3週間は古典的であるように、呼び出されれば現役を務めることもできます。
年に数週間は
訓練のためにどこかに行くだろう
私は予備役にいたときに行っていた私はワシントン州に行った私は
主権の年を間近で個人的
に行っ
た 私は事務局長だった
ので、校正について学びまし
た。本当にエキサイティングな軍の
通信員のような通信の処理を知っています。私は病院のユニットにいました。
それから4年目に
、軍は再編成を行い、私の
仕事はなくなりました。 私は所属する新しい部隊を見つける必要があり
ました
、そして私は国家警備隊のリクルーターと話しに行きました、
そして彼は私が何をしたいのか知っているのかと私に尋ねました
、そして
私は月に軍の語学学校について聞いたことがあると彼
に言いました terey california
と私は日本人のためにそこに行きたいと思っていました、
そしてこのリクルーターの功績は彼が
私が見つけることができるものを見るだろうと言った
その時点で彼
はキャンパスにいて、火曜日か水曜日に私を呼んだと思います。
彼は私に日本語を送ってくれることを保証するユニットを見つけたと言った
ので、私
は予備軍から国家警備隊に
移行し、言語学者のユニットになりました。 グレンデールカリフォルニアを拠点とし、
ロサンゼルスのすぐ外にあり
、数年間働いた後
、学校でスロットが開くのを待たなければならなかったが、結局
は
防衛言語研究所の外国
語に行くことになった。
カリフォルニア州モントレーの日本人センターセンター若い世代の多くの元気
やええyoutubeのように、軍隊を通して日本語を学ぶ人々について聞くことができるのは非常にまれだと思います
ええそれは何でしたか
その機関で
日本語を学ぶのは大変でし
た。フルタイムの仕事なので
、午前8時30分から午後4時までクラスに
います。
そこに
いる言語を勉強するためにそこにいる言語を勉強しているあなたがそこにいる
間にあなたの仕事は大丈夫ですえ
えと、当時の日本語コース
は16ヶ月でした
私はまだ覚えています
クラスの初日はオリエンテーション
または初日だったと思います 教室で
オリエンテーションをしました2日目は大丈夫でした
クラスこれはカタカナです
明日から終わりますテストがあります
ええクラスの2日目はテストを受けました
そして彼らはテストをしてくれてありがとうと言いました
これはひらがなです 明日
はテストがあります
ええ、それは
あなたがええ公立高校のように見るものよりも少し強かったです
ええ
それは私たちが触れ始めた3日目までに非常にペースが速かったということでし
た 漢字
と文法の基礎
私のクラスレートのほとんどは、クラスの最初の4週間をカバーするコミュニティカレッジで日本人の2学期を受講しました。
私のクラスメートのほとんど
は、コースの終わりまでにまったく日本人を持っていなかったと思います。
あなたが行く
新聞はその時にゼロから新聞に行きますそれは
基本的にあなた
は私が言うだろうとの間のどこかで出てき
ますそしてあなたはハイエンド3のように卒業する
ことが
できます
16か月後に大丈夫
になるまでに、そのコースで話す、書く、読むなどに重点が置かれている
のでしょうか。
卒業生は実際
に3つの異なる側面であなたを評価します
読書を話すまたは
読むと聞くことを話すことは3つの主要な
ものです
個人的には、jlptについてあまり好きで
はありません。それは、話すセクションがないということです。それは
明らかに、パトレオンに関する私の全体的
な知識であり、そのようなもの
は、コミュニケーションの重要な部分です。
まるで
言語の骨のように、
いわば語学を習得し、
その機関を卒業した後
、どのようにし
て日本に行き着いたので、その後
、90年に高校を卒業
し、語学学校を卒業しました。  2000年だったので、あちこちで軍隊の
奇妙な仕事にたどり着くのに10年かかりまし
た。コミュニティカレッジに戻っ
て少し
語学学校、次に語学学校、そして
語学学校の後、
サンフランシスコ州立大学に転校しました。
ねえゲーターズは軍があなたの授業料を助成しましたえ
えと私はその時にギの請求書を持っていまし
たええとそれは少し
でした 学校の
授業はかなり良かったです当時はそう
ではありませ
んでした私はそれが
1学期で約1000ドルだったと思い
ます多分すべてがすごいそう
です 何年も前に
そうそうそうそうそう私はそこに
現れますええと私は私の最初の年をしましたええと私は留学を申請しましたえ
えと私は外国
語の京都大学に行きました
基本的には、私が
語学学校に
いたときは、最初は初めて語学学校にいたとき
、1
週間の休憩を取り
、その後
、国家警備隊と一緒に2、3週間のミッションに参加し
ました。 日本での最初の長距離留学は
1年
で2000年でした。それは2001年でした。2002年に
到着しました。911の直前に到着
しました。 今
フリエンと
d彼の部屋で私たちはテレビを見ていましたそして
私たちは奇妙な映画が何であるかを理解しようとしていました
そして彼らはそれが映画ではないことに気づきました
当時は
うーん、翌朝、
私は有料電話に行き、ユニットに電話
して、飛行機に乗って州に戻る必要があるかどうかを確認しました
。 あなたの研究ロボットを気にしませんでした
ええそれは私たちがそれ
がちょっと違って
いたということです私はそれを比較することを知っているという意味
です コロナの前後で
あなたが知っているより最新のアナログええと、
それはそのようなものでしたそれは外から
来た誰かのためのその種の違いでした
ええそれはとても興味深いですそれは
本当に異なっていました私はええと戻ってきました
そして再び私はまだ ガードええと
戻ってきて、基本的に私の最初の
学期に戻って私たちはええと呼ばれた
ので、私はしませんでした 退学する
か、学校
を
休む必要がありました。私たちが出荷したユニットはiraqに
行き、処理中
からすべての
管理手順を実行する必要
があり、戻ってくるまでそこにいました。 一
年が過ぎ
ましたええと、それは私が
戦闘自体を見なかったことを意味し
ますが、あなたはそれが
その年の間にあなたが何をしたかを知っています。
言語の位置
ええと、それは
インテリジェンスブランチの一部なので
、インテリジェンス関連の
ことを
たくさんやり
ました。 学校に戻ると
、1学期または1学期が
終了し、ほぼすべてのクレジットが1学期終了しました。
その後
、ジェットプログラムに適用されました。
受け入れられ、2005年
にジェットプログラムで日本
に来ました。
鹿児島の小さな
小さなコミュニティの温泉は、2つの小さな町
が
合併し、合併後は12,000人の人々が
いました。 その町には今
9000人がいますそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそう
15年彼らはあなたが失ったあなた
は
どこにでも彼らの人口温泉の25を知っている
ええええ私たちが今住んでいるような
もの
小さな町で、鹿児島ではなく
近くで言うと、それとの関係
でどこにあったの
かというと
、車で1時間強
、北
から北への方向です。 北ええ
鹿児島には
サツマハントとオスミハントがあり、
それらが一緒になって私は
北の上の地域にいたので、あなたは
山の北にいたので、火山は
ええとの間の湾にあります
2つの半島の間右
ええ右ええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ ジェット
プログラムに
1年だけいましたか1年だけええええと、
戻る理由がありました
ええと、戻って約1年
半後
、アメリカから来たジェットプログラムで日本に戻りました。
または9月になって
から、ある時点で
再契約するかどうかを尋ねられ
ます。はい、再契約は
12月のようです。後で変更するように求められます。
後の
世代は、3年以内に開始します。
ええと、私は個人的な理由で私が望んでいることを意味します私
は戻って行きたいと思っていましたそしてそれはまだ
早かった
です
帰りたいけど、
帰ってから生活状況が変わったので
帰っ
て
、投資銀行
のプレゼンテーションで1年半くらい働いて、
それから日本と これは実際にはサンフランシスコ
にありました。私がアメリカに戻ったとき
、ジェットプログラムが日本での生活であることを望んでいたことに気づき始めましたが、それは日本
では実際の生活では
あり
ません。 実生活
ええええええそれはそれが日本の生活であるということですそれは
それを置くのに良い方法であるたくさんの手持ちが
あります 私があなたを止めたら
、それは
大丈夫ですので
、ここで簡単に言いたい
ことが1つあります。それは私が日本でよく観察したことの1つで
あり、これは起こっています
私も基本的
に日本に来るのは
あなたがliを始めた後です いつの時代も日本に
いる
と、自分の国
とは違うものや、
事前に予想し
ていなかったネガティブなものを見始めます。
それなら
、州
に戻ったり、どこから来た
のかを知りたいというストレスを感じるかもしれませんが、私が到達しようとし
ているのは、日本にいる人がたくさんいて、
すべてを見ることができるということです。 これらの日本で間違っている
こと
、そしてこれらすべてのことは
確かに日本で間違っているかもしれ
ませんが、同じ個人
が州に戻ったり、出身地に戻っ
て、以前は気づかなかったものを見始めたりする
ことがよくあります
自分の国について
逆文化ええ逆
文化ショック文化ショックえ
えと、まったく
別の人々の人口統計のように、
彼らは州に
戻ってから再び日本に戻って、あなたは
そのカテゴリーに分類されます
少しだけ、
実際に恩恵を受けたと思う
ので、ジェットプログラムで日本に来たときは、
2005年を開催していました。30
代前半で、すでに働いてい
ました。 私たち
あなたは10年以上知っています、
そして
あなた
が大学を
出て日本に来る若い人たちを知っていると私が見る多くの不満は
私が彼らから聞いた職場
や日本の生活についての多くの不満です または
、銀行や郵便局のような
ものに対する欲求不満は、日本ではない
、それは人生である
、それは彼らが卒業した後、彼らがジェットプログラムにやってきたので、卒業後に最初に遭遇するものです。
または他のいくつか、そしてこれ
は大学や家のバブルを持っていないのは初めて
ですまたは
そして私はそれの別の部分は
あなたがあなたがあなたの母国にいる
ときあなたがまだその断熱材を持っているときだと思います
そのyの文化 あなたは慣れているので、物事
は
あなたがそうすることに慣れている方法なので、あなた
は正しいことに
気づかないので、あなたは角や棘や縁に気づかないでしょう、そして
あなたのすべては物事がちょうどいつであるかを知っています」
理にかなっ
ているのですが、
私は仕事の世界を経験したので、日本に来たとき
は欲求不満がありましたが、
これは日本の欲求不満ではないと思っていました。これは
、わずかに異なる味の標準的な職場の欲求不満です。 それ
は
私が何年にもわたって私を助けてくれたと思うということでしたええ
私たちが過去に話したこの現象の最も良い例は、
おそらくジェットプログラムか何かで日本に来る多くの人々だと思います
そして、彼らにはひどい上司がいて
、なぜか
無意識のうちに
これは日本の問題だと無意識のうちに考える
ようになりますが、ジャークの上司のように、全面的に普遍的な
もの
です。  ja パン
あなたは何をしていたのですかこれ
はもう一つの
楽しいものです私は日本に来ましたそしてそれ
は2008年だっ
たでしょう
ええと、私は何人かのリクルーターと話をしました、
そして、いくつかの会社に紹介されて
、オファーを得たので、あなたは軍隊ではなくヘッドハンターの会社のリクルーターについて話していることを知っています
契約を終えたら、私は仕事を終えました。
私は自分の役割を果たしました。私は自分の役割を果たし
ました。
名前を落として
も大丈夫ではないかもしれ
ませんええええとメジャー1ええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ
9の直前の日本11.
ええと私はちょうど日本に来ました 金融住宅危機全体の前に
ええと、もちろん私は投資銀行で働いていた
ので、彼らがすべての請負業者を許可し
、私が請負業者
だったとき、私は
結婚していました 妻は妊娠
していて、成長する金融危機の始まりに仕事がなくて東京にいることに気づきました。
友人の一人を通して世界的な金融危機私
は小さな日本人の会社
を紹介し、次の2年間そこで働きました。
ええと、ええと、311年まで
、東北ええ地震と津波
、そしてそのすべてええ、私は東京に
いまし
た。それが当たったとき、私は仕事に行く途中でした。
私は銀座線に
いました。
電車が走っていたのか、
停車したのか電車が駅に停車しまし
た。iPodがイヤフォンに付いていなかったので、
見下ろしていました。電車が止まると、
人々が乗るときに揺れる動き
があります。 電車の外であなたがたは ああ、あなたはそれを
経験したので、私はちょうど
見下ろしているのですが、それは
午後の早い
時間でした。私は病気の息子の世話をするために朝を休みました
、そして
私は見下ろしています 電車の車
は人が乗り降りしている
ときに
揺れていますそしてそれはまだ揺れていますそしてそれはまだ
揺れていますそして私はこれが奇妙で私が
見上げると誰も動いていないようです
そして
私の隣の日本人の男は私の隣の日本人の男が見ています 私と彼は
地震になりますええ、その後、
私の妻は東京から出たいと思っていました。
あなたはさまざまな理由を知っ
ています。別の友人を通して私はapuに紹介され、
apuでの仕事に就きました
。私は2011年からここにいます。
どちらもアプで働いていたので、
3年半くらいの時間の重複が
ありました。5年間契約して
いましたが、1
年半の終わりに
は基本的に育児休業でし
た。 双子の娘が生まれたので、私
は
その一年中オフィスにいなかった
半年ですが、私たちは
3年半一緒に働いていました
ええあなたはそこにい
ました
1615ishええそのような
ものえええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ 簡単な紹介
apuがアジアで作ったパシフィック
大学
が大学で作ったのは日本の主要な大学の1つです
つまり、それ
は私立大学の1つですが、それは私立大学の1つです。
ええ、
それは日本でトップの私立大学の1つ
です。
大学 圧倒的に日本人の
学生です
が、アプはその大学の支部のようなもので、
アプに行く学生の
半分は日本人で、半分
は外国人で、
外国人の学生も
4年間そこにいます。それは勉強のようではありません。
海外ではapuで留学できます
が、それは超国際的な
環境
です。スタッフの約半数もそうだと思いますが、
それでも
、教員が教員を持って
いるので、2つの大学があります。
6000人の学生基本的に
50人50人が少しだけ
国際的な国内の
留学生を与えたり受けたりします私は今キャンパス
に90カ国が代表していると思います
それは素晴らしい環境です学生
は日本の大学です
が英語か
日本のトラックな
ので、私たちカナダから来ているなら、
ブラジルのインドを知っています。あなたが日本人なら、あなたは一般的
に英語のトラックに来てい
ます。 普通
に日本語のトラックに来る
あなたが最初にすること
はあなたが反対の言語を勉強することですええ、
apuでバイリンガルになることは何もありませんええと、三か国語
の学生がたくさんい
ます
環境は別のものです
それは素晴らしい環境です
ええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ 私
は創造的なものではるかにうまくいく傾向があり
、私はapuで販売をしていました
が、私は
jpがちょうど私が卒業した魔法のような環境であると言ったすべてに同意することを強調したいと思います
ワシントン大学
あなたはアメリカの公立州立学校を知って
いる
ので、私は3年間そこにいました、そして
私はワシントン大学に入学したときの1年間は
ko大学にいました n
だから私は伝統的な私たちの
側を見てきました私は伝統的な日本の側を見てきました
そしてapuはそれが
その間にさえないようなものですそれは完全に他のもののようです
ですから、apuでどのような仕事をしましたか？
私はセールスを
しました。
主に日本の留学生
だけでなく、南東アジアからも日本人学生を募集し
ます。来てみたいと思ったら、このユニークな学校を見てください。
私はapuで何をしましたか？
あなたは国内の入学事務局に
いました最初の5年間はほぼ5
年間学生事務所にいましたそして私は
学生サポートをしました私は主に翻訳
通訳をしまし
た
留学生が
最初に行うことの1つは言語を学ぶことですが
、それは語学学校
ではありませんが、彼らが最初に行うことの1つは、
1年目に言語を学ぶことです。  cond year
時には3年目でさえ
、問題を説明したり、問題を理解したりすることができず
、
奨学金申請書の問題を知っているので
、学生
サポートの解釈と翻訳をすべて処理
しました。
私にとって本当に素晴らしい経験のために作られたのは、
私があなたのすべての学生とすべての留学生を知ることができたとは想像できない
からです
ええ、それは
私が働くのが好きではなかった理由の1つだったかもしれません
ノンストップのセールス
だったので、学生との強いつながりが
あり、学生が応募して、学生がapuに登録した
ようになるまでには至りませんでした。 次のあなたが
知っているのは、ええ
iiiは
、私がそこにいたのと同じ時間にそこにいた多くの本当にクールな学生に会うことが
できました。
でも
、あなたが作ったはずの種類のつながりにはほど遠いです。
それは驚異的でした。それでも
、最初の5年間で、次の5
年間は大統領府に移り、
ソーシャルメディアの
開発に取り組みました。 ソーシャルメディアチームは、
主に入学事務局で
他のオフィスと協力しましたが、他のいくつかのオフィスとも
協力してソーシャルメディアの存在感を
高めました。
私たちが
ソーシャルメディアで大学を本当に代表することを可能にしたチームは、
彼らはまだ
インスタグラムで本当に良い仕事を
しています。
教員なので、apuの教師
はスタッフがいる
ので、
epuでの非ええと教育の仕事のようなことをする人々
は、
すでにそこにいるが、helのように彼らに教えていない学生に再び対処します
問題を抱えて彼らにpingする
事務作業ええオフィス
管理ええオフィスと
管理管理業務は
私たちがやったこと
ですそのスタッフの間で再び学生
の半分と教師の半分
は日本人と国際的そして
日本人と国際的です
がスタッフ自体は はるかに
少ない混合ええ10
パーセント
に近いええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ
25 26 30 ish
他の外国人は、別府
の周りでいつも本当に見かけ
ますええええ、あなたはどこでもみんなに出くわし
ますええええ私は
youtubeを始めましたええと私は1年後に言いたいです
ほとんどの人
は私が前もって書いていたことを知っているので、別府で働き始めました。
しばらくの間、私の芸術的な努力をバックバーナーにかけなければなりませんでした。
ause私はapuでの仕事で上手になる必要
がありましたが、その後
上司と会話をしました。
もっとクリエイティブなことを始めたいと言い
ました。YouTubeや古いものと同じようにやり始めます。
書いていて、彼はそうだと言った
。去年のように、それはまったく問題ない。去年の
apuでそうだね
、そうだね。
編集し
てフィードバックを送ると、プロセス
をスムーズにする
ために協力しますはい、あなたはちょうど
apuをやめましたええと、私は2週間
前にこの時点
でええと1週間半前にええ
本当の理由ええええ
そうええと たぶん、この
最後の
10分間にできることは、このチャンネル
で今後やりたいことの種類について簡単に話し合うことです。
他のチャンネルは、基本的に
大きな問題を明らかにすることなく、良い音に聞こえます。
私は行きます
私のpatreonシリーズの多くの作業を
jpにオフロードして、コメディにもっと集中できるようにし
、
できれば次の3〜4週間以内に、
少なくとも
毎週コメディビデオを作成できるようにします。 それが目標です
ええと、おそらく
次の月、おそらく2か月でそれに近づくことができると思うかもしれません
が
、その後、双子の娘
が学校に通い始めるので、
確かにその目標を達成することができます
はい、一度それが起こったら、私はそうだと思いますええ、
私たちはこの時点でちょうど時間切れになって
いるので、
私は物事をまとめる必要がありますが、うまくいけ
ば、皆さんはjpをもう少し知ることを楽しん
だと思います
多分彼らは軍隊にいたか
、彼らはあなたの話について
普通の人の
話とは違うことを聞いたので、彼らは
あなたに直接質問したいので、多分
私たちがすること
は私たちがどちらかを残すことです メールアドレス
やツイッターアカウント、または
以下のようなコンテンツで、
直接質問したい人
や
、コメントに質問を残したりすることが
できます。そうそう、
私は
umjpにいくつかのアクセス権を与えました。  youtubeの
機能なので、彼は返信できるようになります。
多分、私はあなた
がjpを知っていると言う
でしょう。
この点ですが
、ご支援いただきありがとうございます。また
お話しします。またすぐにインターネットでお話しします。